à deux semaines de la rentrée scolaire
alors qu'une huitième bac de kobe 1920
pour un drap l'horizon la ventilation
dans les salles de classe et elle
adéquate
c'est une question que se posent bien
des parents comme olivier drouin je
m'attends que le dossier soit réglé
j'espère je croise les doigts comme tous
les parents le ministre de l'éducation
en visite dans une école de montréal
précise que les 90000 capteur de co2
sont tous installés et fonctionnelle
dans l'ensemble des classes du québec
lara trick s'en viennent c'est la plus
belle des rentrées en tant que ville
c'est à dire que c'est la troisième
rentrée en tant que co vide mais cette
fois ci les travaux ont été faits les
enseignants seront donc en mesure de
constater en temps réel la qualité de
l'air de leur local afin que son niveau
du co2 soit en deçà de 1000 ppm soit
1000 parties par million toutes les
classes devraient atteindre cette cible
de moins de 1000 bébés aiment quand on
devrait atteindre sol de cet automne
mais pourtant sur le site du ministère
de l'éducation on précise bien qu une
concentration moyenne quotidienne de co2
inférieur à 1500 ppm peut être utilisé
comme paramètre de confort adéquat
hormis 500 ppm c'est une norme qui est
loin d'être acceptable selon cet expert
en ventilation quand max 2005 ça c'est
qu'on est très tolérant au risque
d'infection
si on est dans ce que beaucoup d'experts
parle comme une ligne est qui et qui
convenable on a plus dans leur de 800
parties par million certains
le gouvernement de la coalition avenir
québec estime avoir investi près d'un
demi milliard de dollars depuis juillet
2020 pour améliorer la ventilation des
écoles principal responsable de la
transmission des airs au sol lecteurs de
lakovic 19 l'installation urgente de
ventilateurs mécanique ou d'échangeur
d'air toi aussi tu re complété d'ici la
rentrée quoique dans plusieurs cas on
privilégie encore l'ouverture des
fenêtres